for some time now
and even today and beyond I have been
living in a sober house you know I've
had a struggle with cocaine in my past
and I never went to a place to get the
treatment I don't know how except God
was sitting on my shoulder and I just
stopped but there are people in your
family it might be you who've been
struggling and I wanted to know more of
the story so this is my autobiographical
story and I'm living it and I'm telling
you this Wendy Williams making the
emotional confession that she's staying
in a sober living facility on her talk
show Tuesday when Dee returned to her
daytime gig just two weeks ago after a
months-long break
Wendy's team said her time off was to
manage complications from Graves disease
an autoimmune disorder and a shoulder
fracture the TV personality suffered in
December either you're calling me crazy
or the bravest woman you know I don't
care the 54 year old did not address the
reports that she relapsed while on her
break during the tearful announcement
only Kevin and Kevin have known about
this uh not my parents nobody nobody
knew I am driven by my 24 hour sober
coach back to a home that I live in here
in the South I mean in the tri-state
with a bunch of smelly boys who've
become my family doors locked by 10 p.m.
lights out by 10:00 p.m. so I go to my
room and they stare at the ceiling and I
fall asleep to wake up to come back here
to see you so that is my truth Wendy has
been more than open about her struggle
with addiction in the past I lost over a
decade of my life being hooked on
cocaine I was a functioning addict
though I report to work on time
and I walk in and all of my co-workers
including my bosses would know but
instead of firing me you say I would
grab my headphones and arrogantly walk
in the studio and dannan fire me because
I was making ratings she and her husband
Kevin hunter even launched their own
organization the hunter foundation to
help those battling substance abuse it's
not something to be embarrassed about
you know you've got to grab your kid and
don't be ashamed and find the resources
in your community the various you know
outlets and start the conversation start
the conversation and don't be
embarrassed
don't be embarrassed because that's what
stifles substance abuse
you